if there was like One supplement that I
get asked about the most on my weekly amas
or in comment sections it's creatine and
honestly I probably avoided talking about
it casually because there's just so much
here to unpack especially in the context
of women's fitness body composition and
overall health so if you're a woman and
you've ever considered adding creatine
to your stack you definitely need to
watch this first hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome back to my channel [Music] thank you
[Music]
in today's video I will be chatting all things
creatine for women how it can enhance or affect
your weight body composition mental health and
your productive life cycle but also at what cost
a quick note here that we are talking about body
composition and fat loss today so please feel free
to skip this video if it's not supportive to your
journey and also please note that I am using the
term women for brevity here today even though
I acknowledge that the biological effects that
I'm discussing could also apply to folks who
do not identify as a woman and a big thank you
to the team at unlocked Fitness for their expert
support on this video these are my preferred RDS
for any weight loss or Sports Nutrition needs
so definitely check out their link below for
one-on-one Support also don't forget to hit out
my description for my free Hunger crushing combo
ebook And subscribe if you are not already okay
first let me quickly hop in here to tell you about
my sponsor loaming so my family and I are really
into gardening my husband is definitely the Green
Thumb in the family but I love benefiting from
it when I can just like walk outside my yard
and it feels like my own little secret Oasis I
feel like it's been a really important Hands-On
teaching tool for my kids it's important to me
that they understand where their food comes from
and that they're already starting to think about
ways to help support the environment taking care
of our planet is one of our favorite things to
talk about I mean my eldest is already quite the
environmentalist so when I heard about loamy
I was really excited to add another step to
our gardening lessons with our kids loamy is a
countertop electrical composter that transforms
food scraps and waste into soil in four hours not
only has to significantly reduced the organic food
waste that we're putting out for the garbage
truck each week but we get nutrient dense soil
for our garden and plants my son told his camp
counselor very proudly that he's been helping
the Earth get healthy after all the forest fires
near home and I don't know that just as a mom that
just makes me so proud so if you're getting to
gardening or trying to find little ways to cut
back on your food waste check out loamy.com com
slash ABI in the description and use my promo
code Abby to get 50 off of your loamy okay so a
quick little overview here folks creatine is a
peptide made up of three amino acids methionine
Glycine and Arginine without getting too into
like the Nitty Gritty of what creatine actually
does just know that creatine can regenerate ADP
or adenosine diphosphate into a TP or adenosine
triphosphate and ATP is our energy source at
the cellular level the human body produces
approximately one gram of creatine per day
women specifically biosynthesize a bit less so
around 0.8 grams per day we also could get it
from red meat and seafood which amounts to about
one to two grams per day so for most omnivores are
creatine stores sit around 60 to 80 percent full
women tend to fall on like the lower end of this
range because they typically have diets lower
in creatine than men dido4 and vegetarians and
vegans whose stores generally only reach about 55
to 65 percent saturation so the goal of creatine
supplementation is to get these stores as close
to 100 as possible to help improve strength and
exercise performance now the reason why I've been
asked about creatine literally a million times is
that it's not just another semi-boga supplement
it is truly powerful stuff power creatine is often
referred to as the most effective ergogenic
nutritional supplement for increasing high
intensity Exercise capacity and lean body mass
during exercise and while men typically are bigger
users than women they're actually a unique
number of benefits for women so first let's
just quickly talk about its primary use exercise
performance and by association body composition
because exercise improves workout performance
and allows you to train with more intensity it
can induce greater adaptations to exercise by
improving strength power and muscle size all
but one of the studies in this 2021 review of the
literature that specifically tested the effects of
creatine on women observed faster improvements in
strength exercise performance and also sprinting
time creatine can also significantly increase
lean body mass in both Advanced female athletes
and folks who are relatively new to exercise
which could be incredibly encouraging for a
lot of Fitness newbies it is important to know
here that you can't just like take creatine and
expect massive gains in lean body mass unless
you are an older adult for whom we do see some
improvements in strength even without exercise
from creatine you still do need to put in the work
and work now when you hear significant increases
in lean body mass you probably are thinking about
weight loss or fat loss so let's talk about this
because it's often the promise of fat loss that
draws people into using supplements like creatine
okay folks don't get at me here but creatine does
not result in fat or weight loss in fact it
may actually make the number on the scale go
up a little bit because the increase in lean
mass includes both muscle and some water that
it's stored with both of which can increase the
number on the scale so of course this is a really
good time to remind everyone why said number is
BS because if you're training harder and you're
gaining muscle you're gonna look a little bit
leaner so fat loss and weight loss is not a major
benefit of creatine but improved body composition
can be and speaking of unique benefits there may
also be some use for creatine supplements
for blood sugar control so creatine seems to
increase the function of glucose transporter
Type 4 which then brings circulating glucose
to the muscles and out of the blood as a result
one 12-week study found that those who combined
creatine with exercise improved their blood sugar
control better than those who exercised alone now
this data is still very exploratory but with
the growing interest in blood sugar management
right now I do think it is some pretty exciting
research to watch now what I find fascinating and
unique about creatine is that it not only improves
physical performance and health but also mental
performance so it turns out that creatine can give
you both the brains and the bronze so let's talk
about women creatine and depression so depression
is about twice as prevalent in young women versus
men and there are many psychosocial reasons for
this but it may also be potentially linked to
hormonal fluctuations of estrogen and progesterone
research has actually examined the role of altered
creatine metabolism and depression and mood in
adults suggesting that low brain creatine levels
may result in low dopamine and serotonin
levels as a result research suggests that
creatine may actually work similar to the powerful
antidepressant ketamine in improving certain mood
disorders and since women are grossly underserved
in mental health and yet in cases of mood
disorders are typically even more in need this
finding may be huge so next let's talk about brain
function and cognition our brains require a lot of
ATP to process difficult cognitive tasks and guess
what we do as women we process all the difficult
cognitive tasks and usually all at once hashtag
multitaskers for life but one systematic review of
the literature found that creatine supplementation
did actually improve short-term memory as well
as intelligence and reasoning this Improvement
is much more evident in vegetarians and vegans
who tend to be more sensitive to supplementation
than omnivores but it's also been shown to improve
recall and protect against neurological diseases
in older adults so yeah in my opinion this
creatine has so much far-reaching potential
as a nootropic for the general population then
as an ergonomic drug for elite athletes so we
have established that creatine has a lot of unique
and pretty substantial benefits for the body and
for women in particular but there are some really
unique considerations for the female life cycle
so let's talk that time of the month in folks
with normal menstrual cycles it suggested that
since protein turnover is greatest during
the lunal phase of our cycle AKA right after
ovulation and right before you get your period
creatine supplementation before your period may
actually be particularly advantageous next let's
talk about pregnancy so pregnancy is obviously
a time of increased metabolic needs and creatine
levels actually tend to be lower during pregnancy
than any other period in the adult lifespan
now low creatine levels during pregnancy have
been associated with low birth weight and preterm
birth and while we have loads of rodent studies
suggesting benefits including reducing neuronal
injury seizures and chronic kidney disease we
have no human trials evaluating the effects of
creatine supplementation during pregnancy and
that's because it's often unethical to study
pregnant women in a randomized control trial
there's currently no reason to believe that it
would be unsafe but it's important to know that
study is like a large one that is underway right
now publish their findings before recommendations
can be safely made finally let's talk post
menopause as we age creatine stores muscle
strength and muscle mass tend to decline creatine
has been shown to act as a countermeasure to these
menopause related declines and may also help to
reduce inflammation and oxidative stress and as
I mentioned unlike with younger women older adults
tend to see benefits from creatine supplementation
even without any kind of intentional exercise so
now you know that there is a ton of benefits to
creatine but the question is at what cost is this
magical supplement even safe well for like the
first time ever yes individuals both healthy and
clinical populations who have taken creatine for
extended periods of time AKA up to like five years
have not demonstrated any detrimental effects from
its use there could be some mild side effects like
GI bloating or cramps or some water waking game
but these are actually rare and a lot less common
in women in terms of dosing the general guideline
is a loading phase of 0.3 grams per kilogram per
five to seven days or around 20 grams per day and
then a maintenance dose of 0.03 grams per kilogram
or about 5 grams daily If you experience bloating
or side effects you can kind of skip the loading
phase it just might take a bit longer to see the
desirable effects while training now whether or
not you need creatine supplements will really
depend on your life stage and goals but as always
I do recommend speaking to a dietitian like my
friends at unlocked Fitness for that one-on-one
support and on that note my tiramisu overnight
oats is looking damn good such a good post workout
snack a great pairing with creatine I might add
but if you guys like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment below if you
have any more burning questions about creatine or
any other nutrition questions that you want me to
answer and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and hit up my description for my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye bye foreign [Music]